hey guys Pete here we got a surprise
second teaser or trailer for mr. robot
season for today ET online posted an
exclusive article and a trailer first
then the mr. robot social media accounts
an official YouTube uploaded a longer
version which later they took down and
then they replaced it with a slightly
different longer version so that had a
lot of us wondering if they were doing
something on purpose
but the final version seems to have
everything the earlier version had with
some additional shots so this will be a
scene-by-scene breakdown of what I
expect to be the final product the new
season 4 trailer opens with the shot of
Elliot's face in the background we see
what looks like the same hallway from
the back-to-work trailer that caused a
lot of us to question if it was someone
different dressed up in the blue jeans
wearing Elias hoodie this trailer
muddies that water a little bit more
because in this shot we see that Elliot
himself is in a hallway that looks
similar to the blue jeans shot we see
this again at the end of the trailer so
I'll come back to this the narration
picks up and we hear Elliot's say is she
listening of course she is she always is
while he's saying that we get a shot of
someone turning up what looks like a
volume knob and see some screens of
audio software the she'd that Elliot is
talking about his white rose and we get
a shot of her at her Island residence in
the first trailer we only saw her
dressed as Minister Zhang and here she's
wearing a dress
it's a weird shot though because she
doesn't have a wig on and there's this
strange glitch cut kind of thing as her
expression changes I'm not sure what's
going on with that because it looks like
it's clearly intentional like it's
supposed to look like it's glitched a
little bit wig on or not White Rose
looks somewhat pleased here which is a
contrast from the first trailer after
that we get a cool looking over a head
shot that doesn't give much away there's
two characters sitting on that bench you
can see a little bit better and the
first trailer that came out because the
words were different but you can't
really make out who it is that cuts to a
body being loaded into a coroner's van
that looks like it might be in a wooded
area there's another ban or a different
vehicle parked in front of this one and
as we move to the next shot of Dom it
feels like these two shots are connected
it isn't clear if they're happening at
same time but the background does make
it look like the same general location
we did see a coroner's van in New York
City in the first trailer but neither
one of these seems to be that same ban
Dom is looking at a burned-out ban and
of course we see Eliot and mr. robot
burning a ban later in the trailer this
is most definitely the fire we saw them
watching in the first trailer and we get
a better idea of how all this stuff
outside the city is connected the
voiceover continues see what's going on
out there
what happened what's been happening we
get confirmation that this is Phillip
price approaching the evil court
building and street clothes like I
mentioned in the first video I mentioned
he was the most likely candidate but
that it seemed odd for him to be out
front dressed down if he was still the
CEO seeing these close-ups of him does
make you wonder if he's been removed
from that role there's a quick shot of
someone walking through a server room or
a server farm with a flashlight and then
we see the shot of Elliot and mr. robot
working in the allsafe building again
the voice-over continues we let this go
white rose will destroy the world
there's a shot of Elliot running down
the street and it looks like he's being
chased by the police here there's a
banner up above that says scores and
that means this is probably connected to
this shot we see later where he's
exhaling against the wall on the street
this is followed by a shot of a street
light turning red on a quiet road
somewhere outside the city and we
definitely noticed there's a traffic
camera above it there's another shot of
the bloody foam which we've already seen
we hear Elliot's say by next week we'll
be dead as we watch why it rose getting
ready in the mirror and then we cut to
Elliot standing on a crowded platform as
the subway arrives in the shot mr. robot
standing right behind him there's a
quick shot of someone turning up the
volume on a keyboard which looks bicolor
anyways to be connected to that first
scene where we saw them turning the knob
and then a shot of Elliot running down a
hallway that looks industrial in that it
has no windows and there are exposed
pipes running along the ceiling that
cuts to an interior shot of Grand
Central Terminal we here we don't have a
lot of time we see that the clock shows
the time as being just before 12:00 we
see mr. robot there
with an earbud in his ear and since it
looks dark outside I'm guessing
something is supposed to happen at
midnight there's a clock ticking in the
background and then we hear white roses
watch beep we see her touch the watch to
turn off the notification and get a
close-up of her face as she exhale
Eliot's voiceover continues as he says
we can take them down together this
seems like the most interesting bit of
dialogue in that it sounds like he's up
against someone else in addition to
White Rose there's a shot of Elliot
Tyrell and mr. robot all together on the
country road at night which is most
likely connected to the burning of the
band we see an elevator arrive at the
third floor and then see that Darlene's
inside wearing that black wig she looks
up at the security camera and then we
see another shot of her inside a room
with a Christmas tree taking the wig off
after that we watch White Rose come down
a staircase and what looks like a
palatial home there are armed soldiers
following her and there appear to be
dead soldiers everywhere the fallen
soldier she's passing looks like a
westerner but you can't see the faces of
the ones that are following her and as
she walks we hear Elliot angrily say
she's going to pay for what she's done
and there's a shot of him pounding his
hands against a window as he continues
she can't hide from what's coming for
her as he's saying that we see an
overhead shot of price sitting at a
table in the museum we see what looked
like dark army foot soldiers approaching
the table while a figure that could be
John is looking on what stands out about
this shot is that there is what looks
like a phone and tablet on the table
along with two glasses of champagne so
Pryce was having a discussion with
someone who got up and left it could be
that it was the man standing with his
coat on holding a hat and that could be
Minister John I don't think we could say
either one of those things is definitely
true but I do think we can say that it
looks like the other four guys are
rolling up on price for sure after that
we catch a glimpse of Elliot being taken
somewhere by a bunch of armed men
wearing dark army masks which could
certainly be connected to the scene
that's coming up with White Rose before
that though we see him lighting the
lighter and burning the band
another shot of him running down the
stairs with Darlene and the wig
following him like we saw in the
back-to-work trailer we don't really get
any more of an idea of what's happening
here but we may be able to connect this
scene to others where she's wearing the
same wig mr. quick shot of Eliot
standing on the subway platform where he
looks like he's talking to his younger
self it's not the same actor because
obviously that actor grew up and it
looked like in the preseason stuff that
they were casting another character to
play a young Elliot and this is super
interesting because at some point
Elliot needs to sort out the questions
that he has and that we have about his
childhood so hopefully him standing here
talking to himself is related to that
process of us figuring out what's going
on then we get another recycled looking
shot of Angela from season three the
first trailer left a lot of fans
thinking that maybe the show is going to
kill her off and maybe like right at the
beginning I haven't really bought into
that idea yet I tend to think they could
just as easily be holding back scenes
that she's in because they might be too
revealing about where the story is
headed either way though we don't get a
new shot of her a little later we see a
close-up of what looks like her eye but
that isn't exactly a proof of life
besides that shot of the eye we get a
couple more of Elliot running before we
cut to him and White Rose and a room
together there's a poster on the wall
that says when a door closes a window
opens which feels like not only a
callback to Elliot's fall but also to
Angela's meeting with White Rose at the
end of season two well we saw her
standing in front of a poster and not
exactly the same but it has that feeling
to me White Rose says mr. Alderson I've
been looking for you and I suppose the
fact that these two will be face to face
in a room in season 4 is the big reveal
of this trailer we get one more shot of
Elliot approaching a door in a hallway
which is similar to the blue jeans shot
and the first trailer and the one I said
I would come back to the wood accents on
the sides of the hallways look the same
in both scenes but the doors are clearly
different in this trailer it definitely
looks like Elliot approaching the door
while most of us agreed that the
character wearing the blue jeans and the
last trailer didn't look like him and at
least as far as I'm concerned this makes
it clear are there two different
hallways with two different doors in the
same building with two different people
approaching them I can't say for sure
but that's the way I'm leaning
I have no idea why it's important this
door here stands out to me because it
doesn't match the architecture of the
building I mean it looks like a door
from somebody's house so make of that
what you will things we didn't see in
this trailer were Leon Irving Veera or
the new character that Jake Busey is
reportedly playing also as mentioned no
real new images of Angela beyond that we
got some answers to questions that the
first trailer posed and a whole lot of
new things to think about I was guessing
there would be a second trailer closer
to the release date now that we have
this one I don't actually know what to
expect I'm hoping there's gonna be more
but we're gonna have to wait and see the
highlights here for me are seeing Elliot
tyrell and mr. robot all together in one
shot even if I don't know what they're
doing out there and the was it looks
like they're all working together which
is awesome because that seems pretty
necessary at this point in the game the
White Rose scenes are all pretty crazy
when you think about it it feels like
this trailer even more than the last one
is giving scenes throughout the season
rather than just in the beginning of it
showing us that Elliot and White Rose
will definitely be meeting face to face
makes me wonder how she'll try to
manipulate the situation we saw our turn
Angela to her side by making her think
she could change the past and get Dom on
her side through threatening her family
but as fans we can't actually entertain
the idea that Elliot could be persuaded
to join her at this point I feel certain
that she will present Elliot with some
information that's gonna make him
question his position possibly question
his reality something about his past or
something about his father but how that
conversation is going to play into the
ending isn't very clear as in does it
happen early in the season to set the
table or is this something that happens
right at the end game more burning
questions I have are is priced out as
CEO of ecore
if he is would that mean he is more
dangerous and useful to eff society
what's going on with all the dead
soldiers in that staircase shot of White
Rose what's Elliot burning in the
and is that scene connected to the
coroner's van that we see outside the
city
why does Eliot say that in a week they
could all be dead and what does that
mean when he says that we can take them
down together there's lots to think
about so let me know in the comments
what you think please like this video if
you enjoyed it and subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already in the
age of streaming it seems like
pre-season interests from casual fans is
at an all-time low but I'm still gonna
be covering everything related to season
four I've had so much fun following this
show and picking it apart between
episodes since I started back in season
2 I'm gonna basically continue making
them whether anybody watches these
videos or not I can't wait to see what
happens and how they wrap this story up
so thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon